avec la crise du code vip 19 la question
des vacances d'été se posent certains
français pourrait privilégier l'hexagone
à défaut de l'étranger l'occasion de
découvrir ou redécouvrir certaines
régions de notre pays pour vous
aiguiller dans vos recherches
le guide du routard cette bible
touristique a été créé en 1973 par deux
jeunes étudiants le but au départ
voyagez pas cher à l'étranger philippe
gloaguen et michel duval ont écrit un
guide qui s'adresse à une nouvelle
catégorie de vacanciers le routard à
l'origine du projet un voyage autour du
monde en 1972 de la route des indes
jusqu aux états unis philippe gloaguen
et michel duval décide d'en faire un
guide au départ refusé par 19 éditeurs à
l'intérieur des conseils pratiques à
destination des routards ces jeunes
voyageurs fauché mais au fait c'est quoi
un routard le routard c'est c'est le
jeune qui voyagent ils voyagent avec peu
de moyens financiers ils voyagent en
stop en voiture en bateau ce qu'ils
trouvent ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils
recherchent une aventure à l'époque les
guides du routard ce sont seulement des
destinations étrangères
à l'image du canada de la turquie ou
encore de l'australie un catalogue qui
fait du routard une référence dans le
monde du voyage dans les années 80 les
habitudes de voyage change l'auto-stop
n'est plus à la mode
le lectorat du guide évolue maintenant
il y a un tas de gens bons qui sont
devenus d'anciens routard ils ont une
trentaine une quarantaine d'années ils
partent avec des enfants mais il trouve
que c'est que
le guide du routard leur donne des
renseignements qui ne trouve pas
ailleurs et continue à l'acheter depuis
donc 14 ans le lectorat change les
destinations aussi dans les années 80 le
guide s'intéresse à la france et ses
régions comme la bretagne ou paris en
l'édition parisienne était victime de
son succès une semaine après sa sortie
le guide du routard paris est vendu aux
deux tiers de son tirage
apparemment les parisiens sont trop
paresseux pour partir à la culture dans
leur ville dans les années 2000 le
routard se diversifie encore paris à
vélo en 2001 des guides de conversation
en 2005 il est loin le temps de l'auto
stop et du sac à dos un ouvrage sur des
restaurants gastronomiques français
paraît même en 2007 nous avons sorti ce
guide du routard petit resto des grands
chefs qui donne des adresses de grande
gastronomie mais où l'addition et rester
abordable depuis sa création en 1973
plus de 50 millions d'exemplaires du
routard ont été écoulés
[Musique]